I think asking everybody to disclose
their data on ethnic diversity in their
business by paygrade so that
organizations had know where they stand
today and realize just just how few
people they have those backgrounds at a
senior level in their business and then
setting aspirational targets at each
level to ensure they do have the right
participation every level in business
but wouldn't that create an awful lot of
red tape I mean as a former business
person people hate that don't they well
unfortunately I think it's necessary
because I don't think the stats would
improve unless people know where they
where their starting point is so you
need to know but to be clear you're not
calling for positive discrimination no
absolutely not no positive
discrimination I'm just saying we need
to make sure we have the same range of
opportunities for everyone from every
background in business one of the other
things that you're calling for is
government procurements not to go to
companies that don't measure their
ethnic diversity I think it's really
important that if you work for either
the public or the private sector that
you should be seen to be doing more in
this space because I think that's right
an only proper for you know all young
people today deserve to be able to do
any job they want to at the moment there
are too many barriers and businesses
stopped them so what do you put this
down to this under representation of be
any workers is it simple racism I think
we found some cases of that but I think
in many cases unconscious biases I don't
think many organizations necessarily
realize how biased they are we all have
biases we don't necessarily always
realize what they are
and I think that needs to change whether
it's from having more diverse short less
every time you hire somebody or promote
somebody whether it's making sure that
you are looking to promote more more
diverse school we're very good at hiring
people in our own image that needs to
change looking back at your career you
obviously had a very successful career
at MIT what were the things that made
that company different about some of the
other businesses that you're writing
about here I think I had real support
throughout my career from two or three
really good chief executives you saw
beyond my color and my gender and I
think that made a real difference to me
personally since you left my t that been
some criticisms of your performance
there how do you respond to that I think
no one's really raised that with me but
equally so I did I built a group I did a
chief executive role for a long time and
you know ten years was enough but I
don't really see the need to comment any
further on that